en marrakech capital turística de
marruecos unas protestas han estado a la
orden del día en el último mes en las
fronteras cerraron hace casi dos años se
había convertido en una crisis para los
trabajadores del turismo y ante la
presión el gobierno ha anunciado la
reapertura inminente del padres
y nos abren la frontera el 7 de febrero
y es una gran noticia para todos pero
vamos a continuar nuestra lucha porque
no queremos que vuelvan a cerrar no
bajes udine newt una tiene una formación
la medina ha estado al frente de las
protestas y es muy activa en el barrio
explica que los vecinos ya no tienen
dinero ni para medicinas
entonces la gente está enferma pero no
tiene ni para medicinas el del bazar
trabaja con el taxista con el
transportista con el de la tienda de
teléfonos con el vendedor de zumos uno
depende del otro suerte
casi el 50% de los hoteles y centenares
de establecimientos de todo tipo llevan
mucho tiempo cerrados artesanos
comerciantes artistas dos años parados
la mayoría sin ayudas del estado
solo espero que no vuelvan a cerrar que
en dos o tres meses no vuelvan a cerrar
estamos hartos de tantos errar de verdad
hermana no tengo para comer si alguien
viene le vendo artículos de 2010 james
180 dólares por 500 williams 45 dólares
siguiendo sus compañeros se han montado
un campo de protesta frente al hotel
donde trabajaban en plena pandemia los
dueños cerraron y dejaron a la plantilla
sin indemnización
hacemos esto por los derechos que se nos
vulneran nuestro derecho a volver al
trabajo o recibir nuestra administración
quizás con la reapertura el turismo la
situación para el bien y sus compañeros
cambien por ahora la famosa plaza llame
al es una silla vacía y es un reflejo de
la agonía que atraviesa más rápido